um i'll close we'll talk about norm norm  great guy uh i won't overdo it about him  but we had a really fun thing me and him  and uh  over the years  i never seen a guy kill that heart and  bomb that heart  and it's a gift  a gift that people would pay that me  a gift to pay that much for a ticket and  he could still walk them didn't matter  what the price they would leave  and when he killed he killed hard very  hard to follow we did a tour i'll show  you a few pictures from the tour that  our friend julie jones took she sent me  this weekend i think they're great and  they're very cool norm watching me on  stage i'm watching him and there i've  never seen him  so norm's great you know that  um thanks for watching if you did  feel free to follow my  car  not my i don't have youtube i do have a  youtube channel oh yeah watch on youtube